the lib dems in government in their
chief secretary to the Treasury George
Osborne's number two with new government
policy more money for local council
housing and a crack down on tax evasion
in less than a month's time a new
affluent team will be in place this team
will look specifically at the next
350,000 wealthiest taxpayers these are
the people who pay or should pay the 50p
rate of tax an extra 100 million pounds
every year that councils can then
reinvest in housing the creation of a
new growing places fund half a billion
pounds that will kick-start developments
that are currently stalled half a
billion pounds that will deliver key
infrastructure and create jobs Nick
Clegg says the lib dems can handle the
unpopularity that comes with government
I think a resilient we're much more
resilient than our critics have allowed
mine that's just been on display again
this weekend he maintains he will veto
any move to scrap the top 50 pence tax
rate his fellow Lib Dem cabinet
colleagues say the ridge must pay there
are alternatives to the 50p tax rate I
mean you're familiar with our party
policy that you know very valuable
property could play a little bit more in
tax as an alternative that you know
that's something we have to discuss
within the college there's a sense of
pride among lib dems here that they are
in government and making a difference
despite a dreadful year of election
results and despite still flatlining in
the opinion polls that round about
eleven or twelve percent the mood here
is remarkably upbeat they're not exactly
popping the champagne corks but they do
seem to believe they're on the right
track outside a different story the t
you see came to birmingham they want the
liberal democrats to leave the coalition
and ditch the conservatives the policy
that they said was going to work is
failing badly and the you know we got
very very anemic growth have you got two
and a half million people on the dole i
think there really is time for the lib
dems start thinking about the policy
they
they've shuffle themselves to the lib
dems don't see entirely I to I with the
t you see in fact delegates here believe
lib dem policies are curbing what they
see as Tory excesses the challenge of
course is persuade the rest of the
country they still got a long way to go
Leonard Garza Sky News in burger